To create the histogram, we'll pass friend count to x
inside of hue plot, and we'll pass pf into data.
When I run the code, I can get my histogram. Looking
at the plot, we can see that the data is squished on
the left side of the graph, just like Maura's plot, and
this graph extends all the way to the 5000 mark. This is
what we call long tail data. And this data can be
common for some user-level data. Most users have friend counts under 500,
so we get really tall bins on the left. But there are
a few users in our dataset with really high values. The higher
values are closer to 5,000, which is the maximum
number of friends a user can have. Moore was interested
in examining the bulk of her data. And, it's the
same for us. While, we may want to investigate some
observations in this tail, we really want to examine our
users with friend counts well below 1,000. All of these
people here. To do that, we'll need to learn something
else, in order to adjust our code, and our plot.